Bra
Aran Eu filmei Maso tirar a captura De
tela empur
Tem ua é s o GL O trigo O trigo Em
si le GL Uma leado le normal nome ingls
né glut é Ess le desn normal sabemos é
desnatado Ele é bem gorduroso bem
gorduroso dura é o Leite olha é o
empurra
empurra é o pode tomar vontade Eu tenho
glut aqui espa espa espa espa SAP por le
le é
Des é
mais éo S que mais Nat porque a para Ole
Oci Vai sub Uma Como Uma Soda tratamento
Industrial é emesa refino refino Uma
empresa Eu Tem problema Ela gosta muito
de suco de lanja Ali V fando ver se é
bom Sen Fala que é Café é
Café vou pegar o Café bom Isso é bom é
bom desculpa gr S um minuto
AZ
Branco acho Vai dar altera a
azan Branco
é
mundo que é
Iso Industrial cafezinho
ua de coco ua de coco
azucar azucar sei pode
ser adante
adante Pou eles
coloc azares
totais aar do do C
aar sei empurra é bom é bom
Ca
Glo test glest Bol
GL ser que D raciocinar Assim Eu
sei
B
problema perché sto
lasciando P Ela chea sta già guidata do
te se vo C l'esercito te me devo le
nuovo
luio come è come è oggi oggi Sim come è
inur esercito te che Consi
blocca No
perché
foro
sentent non guenta non
agenta stentando perché stava esercito
te Sì sì da energia no Sì Isso bom Iso
bom mesmo Café
azucar
a Café
Café conseg blocar Cafè
CAF Us
resando sto parando se io non una cacic
terreno e la Poo caffè Beo leci eh
Maa
eh
disculpa
disculpa estremamente perceptivo se
paciente perceber è m s s
percep
Caiu Caiu o testador a Como Eu tenho
essa Quest da metila provavelmente
Tem umas bolinhas a né
Bol
Bol é bonit bu que se vamos mostrar t o
ren l né Mas Isso Tem Tem muito A ver
Porque Eu tive Esse Esse Esse que o
senhor perguntou né Mas por que que se
aumentou 12 Kg de Uma hora para outra é
SIM Aqua pode Beber o Café Sem
problema S comprar Isso a comprar Isso a
e colocar a funciona funcionar se fosse
verdade é Sen pode Comer de Tudo SIM é
pode pode n Café com os exames todos
quando
eua Café Leite glut e
azcar pode com S
trat bom
favor guardar
Esse do terreno Vai ficar Pros prx
captulo
também a especifica do Dos T terreno Vai
gostar muito sabe que que a parte da da
estrutura Rela entendi
conclus conclus an Bal Tem que Fazer e
Ele Ele Fala para MIM Ana Tem dia que Eu
vejo mais inchada e outros dias menos
inchado e às vezes Eu vario 3 kg No dia
possel possel Eu passo por
Isso Meu intestino é Meu intestino é um
relio maravilhoso Tem dor minha esposa
intolerancia intolerancia hum é
intolerancia Tem hora sin mais inchado
tamb me Trab T Todo
inchado
n non
[Musica]
distur alimentar
S
niio basso mego
al
testi do NV Mas Ao che se consim buscar
os alimentos pode Comer O baiar como
CH a uso pode botar no saquinho
C Mas Assim O que come Em casa que vi
marimoo
e Como Chama boona cura de terreno ffar
cura B diente
vai poder o terreno
recursos recursos pode o
terreno que recursos queas
sei